good morning sherry from the bowtie nate  home studio yeah the freeways are in  actually pretty good shape as far as  crashes are concerned but you're right  lane restriction is definitely going to  surprise you  this is on the western 215 beltway  southbound  now for the past couple of weeks they  were doing some lane restrictions for  the northbound right which during the  morning rush hour really wasn't that big  a deal  but this one is a big deal and i'm  serious you're going to be losing  upwards of 10 15 even 20 minutes  so you're gonna have to leave early  southbound on the western 215 beltway  you're down to one lane  between charleston and sahara last until  10 o'clock this morning  and look at the brake light parade all  the way back towards summerlin parkway  now in the immediate vicinity of the  lane restriction it's really not that  bad  it's everybody trying to come in from  the northwest so  plan accordingly or you're going to be  late where you're going